ma il m'a frappé il m'a descendu
elle ne m'a pas aidé du tout c'est lui
qui m'a jamais fait une tentative de
suicide à cause de lui en 2013 est
amoureuse de lui j'étais à moise lui
téter à quoi celui que j'ai et que
j'étais 120 kg que ces sources médicales
tu sous son emprise complètement 13 on
appelle ça un pervers narcissique hier
au mans comment comment ça se passait
quand tu disais que tu étais sous son
emprise
ça se matérialisait par quoi comment
dans au jour le jour c'est quelqu'un qui
vous descend et qui vous dit que vous
êtes une plus une [ __ ] une moins que
rien en perd en continu il avait
complètement perdu confiance en toi
complètement mais après il vous dit que
vous avez de la chance d'être avec
quelqu'un comme lui et vous le croyez
sur la fin donc toi tu disais que son
lui tu pouvais pas vivre exactement
voilà et donc tu pouvais pas le quitter
je ne pouvais pas quitter à cause de ça
et quand même s'il faisait du mal oui tu
pouvais pas le quitter exactement comme
quand il ya des hommes des femmes
battues reste à savoir justement il ya
quelques mois tu va envoyer des vidéos
montrant tes bras et tes cuisses plaine
de bleu il m'a fait 30 et matam en
quatre heures qu'est ce qui s'est passé
il m'a frappée pendant quatre heures à
la suite de quoi qu'est ce qui s'est
passé parce que c'est incroyable
d'entendre ça en fait ce sont prétexte
c'était parce que je lui avais mis un
coupe-ongles roulier dans sa trousse à
sa trousse de toilette mais il m'a dit
rudi le coupon gré il m'a frappée
pendant quatre heures et j'ai des
hématomes c'est pas du maquillage parce
que lui dit c'est du maquillage fait pas
du maquillage c'est réellement des
hématomes un ballon le vois bien oui oui
en attendant quatre heures tu que 4
arrive m'a frappé d'apporter plein oui
je te sont très ému quand tu revois ça
c'est des souvenirs qu'ils doivent eux
c'était l'année dernière sera plus de
trente hématome ce que vous voyez c'est
une partie mon corps était recouvert
pour arriver à ça là pendant quatre
heures il m'a frappé en traitant de
kaunas c'était deux jours avant mon
anniversaire
tu la quittes et aujourd'hui oui
plus aucune relation avec lui non parce
que je sais que comme tu nous expliquer
c'est que parfois il faisait du mal mais
tu retournes avec lui parce que sa toile
et cette fois-ci nantes puis 2 puis 7
soit là non